[Musica]
non mi piace mai presentarmi come un
artista o meglio la parola artista di
per sé mi piace ma è quello che suona
nelle teste delle persone a non piacermi
solitamente si pensa agli artisti come i
grandi della storia dell'arte non si
pensa mai agli artisti contemporanei che
gli artisti contemporanei sono quelli
che vivono i nostri giorni le giornate
come tutti noi e
ricevono stimoli
da cui
rubare delle cose per poi riuscire ad
elaborare e creare ad esempio
un'immagine come questa semplice che
magari tutti abbiamo visto
e sono delle balle di fieno ricoperte di
una pellicola nera Oppure ancora più
semplicemente delle degli imballaggi
industriali creati con una pellicola
possono trasformarsi in qualcosa di
installativo qualcosa di bello che
dialoghi con gli spazi ed è solo l'uomo
a questo punto che decide
se vivere un'esperienza e azionare
quella cosa oppure oppure no
o ad esempio dei pannelli isolanti che
spesso vediamo in edilizia magari nei
cappotti possono essere visti sotto
forma di pittura con uno sguardo
pittorico Come avete capito Io ho
incominciato a fare questo nei cantieri
edili utilizzando i cantieri edili
cantieri edili sono questi
enormi posti solitamente dove c'è tanto
caos tanti materiali tanto disordine
tanto fastidio Cioè provocano
solitamente fastidio caos sono
enormi posti dove ci sono tanti
materiali ancora in disordine sono
materiali che devono diventare ancora
qualcosa solitamente
diventano delle cose belle per la
società però
questa cosa è
vista in maniera molto disordinata e
i miei primi ricordi di questi cantieri
sono da quando ero bambino mi ricordo
che mio padre spesso mi portava in
questi cantieri Perché lui si è sempre
occupato di edilizia e ancora oggi se ne
occupa e vi posso assicurare che questi
posti per me non erano Né caotici né
sporchi né disordinati
Ma erano dei posti fantastici
immaginatevi un bambino che vede una
cosa del genere sono linee che volano
gli oggetti si spostano sembrano
spostarsi con la forza del pensiero cioè
immaginatevi di essere bambini e vedere
una gru che solleva una trave di 10
metri pesantissima attaccata ad un filo
e
manovrata con un telecomandino Cioè è
proprio è quasi un giocattolo Ma se un
giocattolo enorme e queste travi
sembrano danzare nel cielo
o una betoniera Avete presente una
betoniera
Cioè è vero noi siamo abituati i
giocattoli Ma la betoniera è enorme e
sembra quasi che ti incanti cioè c'ha
queste righe
non lo so con gli occhi di un bambino è
una cosa sono delle immagini stupende e
soprattutto tutto quel disordine tutto
quello squilibrio che ancora non era in
squadra ancora deve diventare qualcosa
mi ricordava molto i miei disegni cioè
quelle immagini comunicavano con me mi
piacevano
e io quando ero bambino Cioè proprio da
piccolo incominciato prima a disegnare
che a scrivere
c'è quel mondo lì
Ho deciso che sarebbe stata la mia vita
avevo deciso che io volevo lavorare con
le immagini quindi ho detto boh voglio
fare l'artista e poi crescendo ho
continuato a dire voglio fare l'artista
e così feci studiare per fare quello per
lavorare con le immagini
quindi
liceo accademia Poi arriva a un certo
punto
dove ti devi scontrare col mondo reale
il mondo del lavoro
e guadagnare qualche soldo per
continuare a portare avanti anche l'arte
che è una cosa non è una passione L'arte
è una cosa che ti senti cioè una cosa
che vuoi portare avanti a prescindere da
tutto per cui è quasi
non dico una tortura però è una cosa che
devi fare e basta In qualunque caso
quindi
decisi che la cosa più facile per me fu
tornare in quei cantieri
a lavorare in quei cantieri ma questa
volta da manovale da costruttore da
operaio E vi assicuro che
la poesia un po' cambiava soprattutto
quando ti devi magari svegliare alle
6:00 di mattina d'inverno al freddo
caricare e scaricare furgoni
era un po' difficile da ritrovare quella
cosa lì però in realtà la magia non era
cambiata e che a muovere tutti quei
materiali a spostare tutte quelle cose a
farle volare con quella leggerezza non
erano più soltanto i pensieri ma erano
persone come me quindi erano ero io e
altre persone che semplicemente dovevamo
spostare delle cose da un punto a a un
punto B sotto delle indicazioni sotto un
disegno che non avevamo deciso noi Però
avevamo dei delle indicazioni per fare
questo
e
mi sono accorto che però quella cosa lì
giorno dopo giorno mesi dopo mesi per me
sarebbe diventata perlomeno avevo il
sospetto che stesse diventando una
routine noiosa
e che mi avrebbe ucciso in qualche modo
e quindi
cioè mi sono chiesto Ma dove Dov'è
finito quell'entusiasmo che avevo da
bambino cioè sono la stessa persona
perché non riesco più a vedere quelle
cose lì Cioè è impossibile che non
riesco più a vederle Beh la differenza è
che quando ero bambino mi annoiavo e
disegnavo
disegnavo tanto per cui la noia può
essere può essere davvero o perlomeno No
anzi lo è È un mezzo potentissimo per
poter cambiare le cose per poter
cambiare la visione
delle nostre giornate di quello che di
quello che stiamo facendo Perché Ci
obbliga la noia Ci obbliga a immaginarci
mondi migliori mondi diversi
e così tornando sul cantiere
ho detto allora è possibile Cioè è mai
possibile che tutte queste persone come
me che costruiscono costruiscono giorno
dopo giorno spostano cose
lo stanno facendo solamente per creare
un'idea sola un'idea che non hanno
deciso loro E se invece tutte quelle
persone
che spostano tutte queste cose che lo
fanno con tanta maestria e con tanta
fatica e se in realtà quelle persone
stessero creando qualcosa senza neppure
accorgersene e da lì che mi sono reso
conto che
potevo essere lo scultore
più fortunato del mondo perché le opere
c'erano Bastava solo guardarle Bastava
solo guardare il punto di vista si
stavano letteralmente creando attorno a
me dovevo solo vederle È così che da
quel punto
anche un ferro appoggiato ad una parete
in bilico lasciato per sbaglio poteva
diventare qualcosa di magnifico per me
qualcosa di che poteva vivere in una
stanza poteva vivere in uno spazio vuoto
poteva cambiare la percezione dello
spazio oppure semplicemente cambiando la
disposizione di alcuni materiali
appoggiandoli
mettendoli in equilibrio o dei pannelli
semplicemente dei pannelli che quando li
trasporti ti si incastrano tra il
soffitto e il pavimento
bloccato in quel momento
bloccando l'immagine scontornando tutto
il resto
può diventare qualcosa che vissuto dal
vivo Ti trasmette un'emozione diventa
viva
o semplicemente anche dei badili
infilzati nella sabbia lasciati nella
pausa pranzo
o dei tubi idraulici Avete mai visto dei
tubi idraulici tirati da una parete
all'altra che rimangono
nell'altra stanza magari e si muovono da
sole cioè quella cosa lì non la vede
nessuno ma se tu per sbaglio stai
passando la vedi cioè un tubo che si
muove con un inerzia pazzesca ed è come
un sono dei ballerini è un'immagine
fortissima ogni materiale
ha un modo di potersi presentare Bisogna
solo trovare quella cosa lì e quando la
si trova È una cosa stupenda
e in questa cosa mi stavo accorgendo che
lentamente mi stavo innamorando dei
gesti delle persone in realtà dei
materiali ma anche dei gesti delle
persone quei gesti involontari quei
gesti a cui non si dà peso che per me
sono i più importanti sono i più
istintivi Secondo me sono quelli che
valgono di più E io sono voglio voglio
voglio dare molta attenzione a questi a
questi piccoli momenti in realtà
vi racconto un ultimo episodio di
recente sono stato invitato
ad un progetto in Val D'Intelvi cavalli
Intelvi è una valle o alcune valli
che dividono la Svizzera dall'Italia il
lago di Como al Lago di Lugano Beh
questo progetto c'è stato richiesto
di realizzare delle installazioni
permanenti che potessero dialogare con
il territorio in più C'è stata data la
possibilità di lavorare con gli
artigiani del posto di quei paesi Quindi
io decisi di andare a trovare il
marmista del paese è un paesino molto
piccolo anche il marmista è piccolo
però quando quando mi ha accolto ha
incominciato a mostrarmi le sue le sue
lavorazioni Italia ad acqua
frese lastre bellissime di marmo cose
stupende che faceva lui gestisce la
gestisce il laboratorio con con la madre
e in tutte queste lavorazioni super
belle io notai che nel piazzale c'erano
questi strani plinti di cemento erano
degli strani spinti verranno circa una
ventina ed erano buttati in poco e là
nel nel cortile Cioè non ce li faceva
vedere erano lì
e quindi visto che a me di solito
piacciono un po' le cose che che vengono
lasciate un po' così
gli chiesi che cosa fossero questi
strani questi strani clienti di cemento
e lui con la madre mi rispose che quei
clienti di cemento li faceva il padre
prima di morire
Il padre era venuto a mancare da poco
quindi capì che quel plinti in realtà si
portavano dietro di sé
un valore affettivo ed erano molto in
più importanti di quelli che di quello
che potevano sembrare
decisi che con quei plinti avrei
realizzato un'installazione
quindi incominciai a giocarci
e senza alterare la loro forma cerca di
trovare
una loro posizione cioè la posizione più
giusta per loro e quindi
decisi di impilarli uno sopra l'altro e
Ma questa cosa viene viene in automatico
Cioè è come se alcuni materiali ti
indirizzano loro dove devono essere
messi quindi comincia a infilarli
e creare usando praticamente tutti
questi clienti
creai queste Due Colonne cioè sono quasi
sono due totem che ho installato in cima
ad una collina e il lavoro si chiama
metamorfosi un po' ricordano anche un
po' le colonne di brancusi però è una
cosa che piace a me personalmente però
non è fondamentale nel lavoro ma la cosa
interessante è che a pochi giorni
dall'inaugurazione io tornai dal
marmista e dalla madre e chiesi chiesi
alla madre così cioè per educazione per
gentilezza le chiesi se sarebbe venuta
l'inaugurazione a vedere la mostra
lei mi rispose che sarebbe venuta
solamente per rivedere il marito
e quindi questa cosa
all'inizio mi ha fatto sorridere ma in
realtà
se dovessi rispondere alla domanda
perché l'artista per cosa fa l'artista
Beh io questo sinceramente non lo so
forse non mi interessa nemmeno però
probabilmente la risposta me l'ha data
quella signora una signora anziana che
ne si occupa d'arte nelle interessa
l'arte soprattutto l'arte contemporanea
forse non sai nemmeno neppure che esiste
ma
ha saputo riconoscere la vita in queste
cose e per cui forse proprio È proprio
Sono proprio lì le risposte
su questo Su questo tema
mi hanno detto che anche
che dopo anche altri hanno apprezzato le
mie sculture
Ma questo magari ve lo racconterò
prossima volta
[Applauso]
[Musica]